self-described alpha males are Waging
War against Grand Theft Auto 6 right now
because in addition to all the hype
after the trailer for GTA 6 broke
records yesterday it's been the talk of
the internet there have also been people
throwing out criticisms and among those
you have the likes of the Tate brothers
and Elon Musk with Tristan Tate saying
I'm not a fan of anyone under the age of
18 21 maybe playing video games with a
goal is to shoot police
officers I just don't think that's good
for Society I feel like you could create
a better
objective with the game you
know I don't think it's a good thing
that people
should go around and assassinate people
I don't think it's a good thing that
just kids
should be um indoctrinated into thinking
they are into war we could do that to a
lot of games like we could we could play
play that [__] for a lot of games
there's a lot of games that are not good
and not not good but it's not it goes
against whatever you should do it's a
game this makes me think of all those
video games that had guns and stuff like
that and they said that it would it
would lead to like gun VI violence and
all this other stuff when there's like
zero evidence and all the scientific
studies that have come out so far say
the opposite this is the same stuff that
you tried to use when they want to ban
any games like Call of Duty and stuff
cuz they said it kids now apparently
these games are somehow bad cuz they
make you want to what do harm to police
officers in real life in the game you
end up murdering hookers and doing all
kinds of other stuff does it make us
also want to have violence against
ladies too like I don't know if these
people really think about the stuff that
they saying when they saying it cuz if
it works for police officers it works
for anyone who's a victim in any video
game and the new Elon Musk also
condemning that part writing on Twitter
that he tried playing GTA but didn't
like doing crime GTA 5 required shooting
police officers in the opening scene
just couldn't do it and while those two
weren't the first people to condemn or
call out certain parts of the game there
was still no shortage of people mocking
their responses online people saying of
Tate heartwarming alleged sex
traffickers draw the line at virtual
violence against police commentators
like Assan [__] right it's incredibly
ironic that two brothers that quite
literally tailored their entire online
Persona as though they are GTA Side
characters taking a stance against the
game like their Hillary rodom Clinton in
200 that is true that's actually a good
take from Mr Hami I'm not I'm not I'm
not a fan of ass son but [__] you got a
you got a point they do come across like
GTA characters
that's a good point and of musk people
saying why would you buy a game called
Grand Theft Auto and expect not to shoot
a cop I mean the video since the trailer
came out everybody been losing their
minds I thought it was going to do well
I didn't know it was going to do 100
million on YouTube and he still Rising I
think it's like 120 now crazy it's it's
crazy but I've never been the biggest
Grand Theft I I played listen and people
gonna hate me for it it's okay I play
Grand Theft Auto 3 when it's in Liberty
City I played Grand Theft autle 3 Vice
City okay I was never into San Andreas
and I stopped there but a lot of the
subsequent games looked amazing I just
Chang genres I did what played all those
games okay yeah I like the franchise I
think the franchise was amazing I
remember playing Grand Theft Auto 3
Liberty City and one of the funnest
things for me to do was picking up a
hooker going into a back alley parking
the car and literally you would just see
the car
shake nothing else would happen but for
me that was like such an immersion it
was so funny to me okay I think that's
all of us
I think I don't know maybe not a lot of
people never play Liberty City to me the
game is just Mindless entertainment I I
hate people who look at media and they
go like well if you play these games
you're going to want to do X afterwards
like where's the science to back this
[__] up and if you guys are going down
that road just remember once you start
you cannot stop well why are we doing
video games where you're the not the
cops and you have to be the robbers
instead and you shoot I think it'd be
better to be the cops you're doing the
punch up punch down [__] with comedy
that's what you're doing
mhm the same thing when people call
about comedians well when you make jokes
about I it encourages your audience to
hate these people when you play video
games that criminalize or Target certain
people you're much more likely to that's
what they're doing that's what they
doing so that's why I don't like this
kind of stuff also makes you seem kind
of boring and lame L really like a video
game like Grand Theft Auto you guys are
whining about that shut up but that's
just my opinion today's video brought to
you by raycon I personally use the
earbuds they're in my everyday life I
use them when I train I use them when I
take a walk I use them when I travel
mostly because there you know there's
noise isolating feature which makes me
able to hear the music in a pristine way
it's a wonderful thing also the Gils
there's different Gils that come with
the earbuds that makes it more
comfortable for you to hear and it
doesn't whenever you shake your head it
doesn't fall off you know it sits in
your year comfortably and you know in
the past year raycon has expend their
business in a great way they are
introducing power Tech which is fast
charging C cables they charge fast they
stay charged for a long time they're
comfortable the sound is wonderful
there's Powertech what do you want more
and right now raycon is offering limited
time bundles on some of their
bestselling products person I like the
fitness kit because it gives me a bit of
variety if I really want to cancel all
the noise it works perfectly it's water
resistant so when I'm sweating I don't
got to worry about these things messing
up on me this holiday season get
yourself premium audio and power tick at
a wonderful great price you just go on
by ron.com slaba and you're going to be
able to save 15% off site white I'm just
saying I got mine I hope you get yours
what do you think about this whole thing
it's just people trying to create
content and they have to talk about it
yeah but as a Haitian aren't you excited
for your people to be represented in
Vice City I don't care they were you
look like you should be in the game that
was there was I look like I should be in
the game yeah you look like you should
be one of the NPCs I have to killed
before I get to like the guy who
actually has the quest I wouldn't mind
you wouldn't mind look at you being so
humble I'm not humble appreciate you how
what you want me to say yeah I I would
mind at least you be in the video game
Ethiopians we never go to make it into
San Andreas that was my last shot no
you're more you're more like a um what
GTA what say some [__] [__] no not not
even or
Minnesota GTA Washington Capital City I
wouldn't say I wouldn't say GTA but you
you strike me more like a Assassin's
Creed uh like like night they're going
to do a version where it's in Egypt
and I do one that's in Ethiopia okay
you'd be there definitely I hope because
I'm Ethiopian yeah makes sense yeah
that's it all right I really see you
like something like that you know they
did the Black Flag Black Flag was fire
Pirates like it's like a that is the
last Assassin's Creed game that I really
like exactly like black flag is like
Pirates and most of you are pirates
facts say
facts fact and
Somalians I'm just kidding hey y'all
like ass we like booty what what
Pirates no still didn't get it Pirates
Booty that's like the things they
loot so when pirates steal treasure they
call that booty AR booty you've never
heard this before
no pause cuz you don't know about it but
it's a real thing okay yeah y you don't
play video games with pirates no I don't
no definitely not uh you know I like
Shooters and I like races where do you
think the word booty came from possible
I believe you like I'm all right I just
my job here uh on this channel is to
make me look sus yes to question you I'm
not it's for me to question you booty
pirate booty booty
pirate you did that to yourself booty is
treasure money jewels and the likes
obtained by criminal means especially
plundering plundering and piling
cool if you're in the Caribbeans on
vacation you could spend some time
looking for pirate booty that still
sounds
why why you have to do we like that it's
funny how we're both right yeah but I
feel more wrong booty booty um let me
get some let me get some booty oh gosh
just let people play video games that's
what yeah for real if you don't like it
just don't play it you don't want to do
I didn't like the crime aspect you're
going to that was a good point [__] the
thing is called a [__] crime and also
it's like you guys make all the wildest
jokes in the world you love doing it I
don't mind it I support it even though I
think you guys are weirdos I don't think
it's a bad thing that you like making
funny jokes at the expense of whatever
group are you guys now advocating for
violence issues are you guys now
indoctrinating people against these
people I don't think you take that
stance so I don't know why you're doing
it with video games specifically just me
person I remember there was a upro back
in the days when they did that they did
that there was one that was like kind of
in Florida or something like that and it
was uh Lil Haiti yeah you're talking
about Vice City yeah and then it was one
Mission that's my favorite one there's
one there's one mission that they
removed it was called kill the Haitians
facts and they removed it because it was
like a upro you can't say that and this
and that people got mad I get it me I
was like you kill a b you kill a bunch
of Russians and that's fact you kill a
bunch of serbians that's fact that's
that's fine everything is all right
everything is all good but then you I
understood why people got mad I was not
one of these people I think all this
controversy like all the Pearl clutching
from conservatives on this issu is
hilarious to me all it's going to do is
make the video game more popular even
now they got me talking about it and I
don't really talk about video games on
this channel the same thing that happen
so I'm probably going to play it and all
this stuff serves to Market this game
every time this game comes out there's
always a lot of pearl clutching about
some aspect of it and guess what the
game just continues to grow popularity
so y'all can keep whining and keep
crying the game going to be more popular
and it looks amazing quite frankly even
I want to play and I'm not the biggest
Grand Theft Auto person I got a PS5 home
you can pass by and just play it I got a
PC why would I play it on a console Fair
always PC Master race Fair that's it
fair that's how we do the game that's
that's actually the first time I played
GTA was on a PC um it's the same thing
that happened with Hogwarts y'all pooke
about it you were pissed off about it
and then what happened blood Buster like
what you like you're doing the same
thing over and over it's like like you
[__] never learned but it's
okay people need to complain and that's
fine I think I think the game is going
to do fine and it's going to last
another 15 years before they doing
another one absolutely I agree 150%
anything else you want to say n let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below